welcome to this video playing a spin
doors from Turkey yeah what do we get
yup this is also interesting creep on
opening white is playing without see for
now we play that okay so what what
exactly is your compensation for the
pond that I'm curious to see I'm just
take take things first ask questions
later yeah it's not them it's not like
ridiculous or anything what he did with
interesting so Knight takes e4 is his
idea technically hmm okay
yeah can I keep this material I'm trying
it will be it will be a bit of them will
be will be dangerous but I'm trying to
keep the porn
that Queen a force very dangerous
probably intending that i take c forum
yeah I that's very dangerous very very
dangerous yeah I am if you why I could
have played queen bee form that was a
mess I should have played queen before I
guess low key
twin before I miss dad it's still in
this position so let's say rook see one
queen bee form that basically ends the
whole thing no no it doesn't you can
still take it takes you 40 okay but look
see what I can cancel right night ac for
DC for Roxy for I can check e5 some I
don't think it's going to work
ultimately yeah I'm crawling my way up
again and in the readings here to 377
I've been on a buff I've been above 2500
for a long time but then I had this this
this big slump the I off when I lost six
games in a row and I'm still in the
phase of recovering from that reading
wise okay what is this
Jim just struck here maybe look g8 or
something or what is the best way to do
this
yeah i'll just put put pressure on the
beef ponyo that's also good using this
somewhat unlucky night position
hmm yeah okay Queen before it's not
really doing that much maybe I should
play like h6 once in a while yeah let's
do that not getting back ring rated as a
plus look before you create it's a good
idea actually let's do that okay I don't
mind that getting the bishop over now to
be six it's definitely better on e6
compared to c6 covering you see form so
why wants to put the night down
hmm that's not helping me much but not
not really a problem I think Queen a
bishop f5s maybe a movie setting up pin
them
have to make sure not to it was much
more time
mmm
isn't as strong come on let's do that it
really cannot believe that's not working
I didn't calculate that really but that
that should work really should work jack
is yes 93 I didn't see that more night
III
that's what silly right 93 edges totally
overlooked
time warning what I thought I had
prevented then
hmm
I was a silly idea to take on g4 and a
technically winning position you
shouldn't do fancy stuff really Wow
queen of three white resigns yeah my g4
wasn't a good idea yeah I wonder about
this opening if he had something there
it really was a bit bit dangerous there
what but okay I have to take that out
it's no question there okay d5 and he
went 95 queen bee six hmm so what about
this now an engine gives equal yeah he
actually am this is a this one this is
great this is great for what which means
some that this was a mistake he could
have taken and then I needed to go down
no then he takes on the same form may be
here it might be still feasible but it's
really dangerous yeah I knew that I was
living on the edge there with them that
I think here I'm out of the woods yeah
call compass on minus one that doesn't
see anything castle is a key get the
King out yeah MBLAQ just wins fairly
routinely unless you unless you want to
play fancy stuff and take them it
actually does win okay the computer
gives a win rook edge for I'm
controlling f1 mate on h2
that simple okay that also wins so I had
the right feeling they're the right
hunch okay that's easy after the pho but
computer doesn't see a defense there
yeah probably it is too much i have d
for coming and even rook b6 g 6 all this
stuff he is not defending so it was
right it was just not necessary at all
to make it done make it that complicated
ok all the fun game thanks for watching